[Music]
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
let's talk today for a while about how
governments
can and should deal with recessions this
is an important question right now the
unemployment rate is skyrocketing more
than 20 million people 2024 23 million
people
have lost their jobs in the last five
weeks we learned today that gdp was
down almost five percent in the first
quarter of the year
we are seeing some ideas that second
quarter gdp could be down as much as 20
or even more so we have a serious
situation here
recession depression and we need to
think about
what are the options for what
governments can do what has trump done
and is he doing a good job or isn't he
doing a good job and what i want to
suggest to you today
is that given the circumstances donald
trump has actually
used most of the correct measures that
are available under the paradigm of
keynesian economics
to deal with the recession but he's done
it
in a completely incompetent crony and
slow way
and these are policies that are direct
contradictions to what republicans claim
are the policies that a government
should institute so there's also an
element of hypocrisy but
we'll get to that so to start with
governments have
two major sets of sort of tools at their
disposal
monetary policy and fiscal policy and
very simply
when we say fiscal policy we mean
government spending to influence the
economy
and when we say monetary policy we're
talking about treasury management
in our case it's whoever manages the
currency treasury management of the
money supply
and of interest rates so fiscal policy
would include things like spending on
infrastructure during a recession to
create jobs
hire businesses to fix bridges the
businesses pay
those employees that are doing the work
those employees then go and spend that
money
in the economy helping the grocery store
and the landscaping company even higher
and they hire and so on and so forth so
that's
fiscal policy then you've got monetary
policy monetary policy would be for
example
cutting interest rates uh to encourage
loans making loans
cheaper so that people will go and
borrow money
with which they can pay for expenses buy
things
maybe pay employees etc when coronavirus
hits businesses start to close
people stop traveling a bunch of things
happen
without government into intervention
that aren't good
this increases unemployment naturally
there's a demand collapse people stop
going to restaurants
so the restaurant no longer needs their
workers so they lay them off
which means the restaurant owner isn't
making any money they can't pay their
rent or maybe they can't pay their
utilities so that affects their landlord
the restaurant doesn't have customers so
it doesn't need to buy food
so they stop spending with the food
supplier the food supplier doesn't need
to buy as much stuff
from farmers the farmers no longer need
as many employees i think you can sort
of understand that
now the the food example
is a more interesting one because you
see a demand
reduction at restaurants but an increase
at grocery stores but
as we've learned with toilet paper
oftentimes the personal
and commercial supply chains for some of
these goods
are separate so that's sort of a detail
but i think you generally understand
the the idea here the other thing that
can happen in a recession
is that you get a deflationary spiral so
in the same way that if everybody wants
hand sanitizer the price of sanitizer
gets driven
up up up which we saw about seven eight
weeks ago
if for example nobody's driving around
this leads to a drop
in oil and gasoline prices which we've
seen now we may not care that much about
oil prices being low
it sounds intuitive that lower prices
are just good right i mean if we're in a
recession and stuff costs less
that's good it means people can afford
more of it the
problem is that it can cause more
unemployment if you run a business
and suddenly not only do people want
less of your stuff
but you have to lower the price because
people aren't willing to pay as much for
it
that furthers not being able to keep
employees on
so you lay people off which means they
don't have money to buy stuff which
means the deflation continues
that's why it's called a spiral in a
healthy economy
you might see some deflation because we
get better at making something
so if we become much more efficient at
making a particular product
we lower our cost to make each one of
those
items and as companies compete with each
other whoever can increase
productivity and lower costs can maybe
gain more market share so that's okay
that's a good example
of prices coming down deflation
deflationary spirals in a recession
aren't good so let's now look at the
things donald trump has done or things
that
that have been done if not by donald
trump personally
so the fed cut interest rates great
that's monetary policy
that's the right thing to do um the
treasury has
created these ppp programs paycheck
protection
plan programs where the interest rate is
it's effect effectively negative you get
money
and as long as you use it for the right
things the loan doesn't have to be paid
back in full
that's the correct thing to do now the
problem is
they did it in the crony capitalist way
that trump always seems to do it took
too long
there were all sorts of of logistical
failures the system didn't
actually start distributing money for a
month or longer
money ran out too quickly a lot of the
money went to really large corporations
and other institutions instead of small
businesses small businesses ended up
not being able to get money trump has to
scramble
ask for more money and ask for money
back total disaster in its
implementation but
it is policy that makes sense now
there's a practical way in which ppp is
kind of a blend of monetary
and fiscal policy it's sort of like
low interest loans which is monetary uh
but forgivable loans to business are
sort of like government spending which
is fiscal policy but that that's kind of
a detail in terminology
another important monetary policy uh
component is expectations management
this is part of why remember we talked
last week or the week before
we get bad unemployment news and yet the
stock market sometimes goes up what's
going on
managing expectations is part of
monetary policy
you tell the public in advance what you
expect to see happen
so that it more smooth this is the goal
right it more
smoothly gets priced into the markets
and then when the news hits
it's not a shock to the system because
the markets were expecting it anyway
that is a form of monetary policy
expectations
management so let's now talk about
fiscal stimulus
you can do fiscal stimulus by cutting
taxes so when trump proposed it didn't
happen but trump proposed
what if we do a waiver or a moratorium
on the payroll tax
until the end of the year that would be
a form of fiscal stimulus through a tax
cut
you can also do fiscal stimulus by the
government spending money this can be
buying things this can be hiring
companies to do stuff
it can also be just the government
sending people checks could be a
one-time payment which we've seen could
be
by increasing unemployment benefits what
we're talking about is deficit spending
there are sort of people on the right
who like to cartoonify this as
printing money we talked last week with
stephanie kelton about that
calling it printing money is not really
an accurate term what we're talking
about is deficit spending we're talking
about
digitally adding money to people's
accounts now again
trump is doing this he's boosting
unemployment
benefits that's fiscal policy it's
getting money to people which people can
then spend
increasing aggregate demand maintain
prices
relatively level more level than they
otherwise would be when trump
cuts twelve hundred dollar checks or
really the treasury does
that's fiscal policy it's government
spending
now they also sent billions to some
industries
airlines cruise companies that's also
fiscal stimulus and
it is the right tool but the problem has
been again
implementation took way too long not
nearly enough money
for the average individual a ton of the
spending was done with companies that
really shouldn't be the priority
should have been more money for
individuals we heard last week
from billionaire investor chamath
polyapidia
who said that you know some of the
companies being bailed out these are
really bailing out
these are bailouts of the billionaires
who are speculating not the employees
if you really want to bail out employees
you can do it in a much more direct way
in addition trump has done it in a
completely crony capitalist way
he's reduced oversight which has turned
some of these bailout funds into
essentially slush funds
he's used government money to buy things
like ventilators and ppe
that stimulus except there's always
something weird when trump does it like
the company that is bankrupt with no
employees which has gotten a big
contract
to essentially just middleman the
purchase of a bunch of masks
way above market value so it's the right
tool
it's being done in a crony capitalist
way the focus
is often wrong it took forever millions
have still got nothing the univ the
unemployment insurance supplements have
still not been received by a lot of
people
so in short donald trump has used the
right tools
under the keynesian paradigm and i'll
talk more about that in a second
fiscal policy monetary policy but he's
done it in an incompetent way
and it of course is of course massive
hypocrisy because what we hear from the
right
year in and year out is one we don't
have the money for this that's clearly
untrue we found it right and
it's again it's not really finding it
that's a misnomer but
we were able to do it despite
republicans saying
it's not possible so there's the hip uh
hypocrisy element
and number two um you often hear
republicans saying that
these types of techniques don't actually
work and yet here they are saying hey
we've actually got to do it so
incompetence and hypocrisy but the right
tools
have been used now what hasn't trump
done that he could have done
infrastructure spending trump has talked
about doing infrastructure spending
it would be important to do six solid
months of infrastructure spending so
have the government spend
on fixing roads bridges tunnels the
electric grid could be bolstered water
supply could be better protected there's
tons of things that could be done
they would boost employment they would
inject money
and when we come out of this whatever it
is we would be better prepared we would
have
better infrastructure to resume all of
that economic activity it's not been
done
it's time to do it trump should have
already gotten this going
he talks maybe it'll happen in the next
phase we don't know
that certainly has been a mistake now
let's zoom out from all of this
why everything i've been talking about
these fiscal policy tools these are what
we call
keynesian tools they're from the school
of fiscal policy founder
john maynard keynes our government has
these tools available instead of other
tools
because keynesian economics are sort of
the orthodoxy and this is based on
you see a recession fundamentally as a
demand
shortage and you then take these
reactions of fiscal policy that we've
described
that is not the only way to see the role
of government
before and during a recession or a or a
depression
a more progressive economic worldview
would say
all right david you've accurately
described the keynesian tools
but those tools are not proactive they
are reactive so i'll give you some
examples of what
a more progressive proactive perspective
would be
a more progressive economic perspective
would say
the federal government should always be
bolstering state unemployment insurance
so if they did that all along and people
got more money from unemployment
insurance if more money was available at
the state level
then you wouldn't see this panicked
scramble to do it now
but you wouldn't see the decrease in
demand that you were seeing now because
people don't have money
another perspective the federal
government should
always be funding more education and
other government jobs
so that when you have a recession a lot
of those jobs just continue
and you avoid having to bail out as many
companies with loans
you avoid having to send as many people
1200
checks because a lot of these government
jobs including an education can simply
continue now there's a that's that's a
political perspective that
right-wingers often disagree with others
would say if we had permanent universal
basic income we would
obviate the need for as much of this
desperate spending
because people would already be getting
that baseline income from the government
and thus this pandemic recession would
be less of an emergency it would still
be one but it would be less of an
emergency if we had
here we go now government-run health
care
you wouldn't need trump negotiating with
insurance companies to waive co-pays on
coronavirus testing or treatment
it would simply be done because the
government is more involved in health
care so
that exceeds our time today but the seat
i'm planting is
trump has used the right tools given the
system we have
he's used them incompetently but there
are more progressive economic
perspectives which would
say if we had much more government
involvement all along in employment
in fiscal policy all the time it would
prevent as much of an emergency need
for that to be done right now many
people don't want more government
involvement and that's a political
debate
so i hope that this is useful to people
there's been a clamoring for more policy
stuff like this
i'll produce what the people want let me
know let me know your thoughts
on this particular segment on twitter at
dpac
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are joe
craig and
mark laprade joe and mark thank you for
your support very much appreciate
it also want to say thanks to today's
longtime sustainer of the day that's
michael
cercharo who has been a member for
almost five years grab a membership
don't be shy
at joinedpakman.com all right it is the
time of the week where we get to hatred
mail a professional interpretive reading
of the hatred mail that i receive
quick reminder about hatred mail because
if you aren't pro-life you deserve the
death penalty
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate david pakman
because america and because
freedom all right a lot in this one many
allegations let's take a listen to it
together
neo-liberal shill david park man
admits he's an accomplice of donald j
trump
david parkman is a shill for the new
world order illuminati
luciferian cabal that is doing
everything in its power to destroy
the united states amy robot knows that
epstein was murdered
david parkman lies about pizzagate as he
knows it's real
david park man you corporate shill can't
wait until you go through with quitting
youtube
yeah you know this neoliberal thing um
just
let's assume it's not a troll and you
really think that i i've become some
kind of right winger
check out over the last 10 years on the
show every few years
i will do a bunch of different political
compass type tests
and every time i do it i have actually
moved to the left
i am more left today than i have ever
been before in my life
now as far as you know lied about
pizzagate quitting youtube stuff like
that
i don't know what you're talking about
but if you really want to do the
homework and see
have i become more conservative or or
more left over the years
the data is out there my friend check it
out remember that you can use the coupon
code
hatred 40 to save 40
off of any membership at
joinedpakman.com the coupon code is
h-a-t-r-i-o-t
4-0 you save 40 the hatreds cry
i've seen them do it every time that
that coupon code is used on my website
the current administration is going to
go down not
just as one of the most incompetent but
as one of the most
uncaring and immoral administrations in
modern american political history
and why am i saying this today i mean i
could really say it on any day but
yesterday vice president mike pence went
to the mayo clinic for a staged
photo op and he refused to wear a mask
now
a mask aside you could make the argument
he really shouldn't be going at all
traveling from washington dc to
minnesota at all
especially for someone like pence who's
around a whole bunch of people all the
time
going to a place where people are being
treated for coronavirus
and other serious conditions introducing
germs why even do it it's a bad idea he
shouldn't do it at all
but he went he went for the photo op and
he was told
to wear a mask and he did not as you can
see if you're watching today
everybody wearing a mask secret service
the patient nurses people in the back
room
but mike pence not wearing a mask
the mayo clinic tweeted quote mayo
clinic had informed vice president of
the masking policy
prior to his arrival today they told him
but pence
refused to wear a mask the mayo clinic
ended up deleting their tweet about
having told pence about the mask policy
about three hours after they posted it
were they pressured by the
administration we don't know
but that tweet was since deleted by the
mayo clinic
uh here is mike pence surrounded by
people with masks he's the one guy in
the room without one take a look take a
listen
[Music]
and this started and got approved with
the fda with mayo
in two weeks instead of these related
notes
even faster than that uh dr marks from
fda sent us a protocol on march 30th i
worked closely with them so why didn't
mike pence wear a mask
he was asked and he says because he is
regularly tested for the virus
and he wants to look people in the eye
take a look
mr vice president there's obviously been
some controversy she got here about the
decision not to wear a mask around the
mayo clinic is
the governor and other officials here
did can you just walk us through why you
made the decision not to wear the mask
even though the clinic
said that they tweeted that they asked
you to do so
well let me say um as vice president of
the united states i'm tested for the
coronavirus on a regular basis
and everyone who is around me is tested
for the coronavirus
and when the cdc issued guidelines about
wearing a mask
it was their recognition that people
that may have the coronavirus
could prevent the possibility of
conveying
the virus to someone else by wearing a
mask
and since i i don't have the coronavirus
i i thought it'd be a good opportunity
for me to be here
to be able to speak to these researchers
these incredible healthcare personnel
and look them in the eye and and say
thank you he wanted to
look people in the eye to say thank you
does mike pence know that you don't
cover your face i'm sorry that you don't
cover your eyes with the mask you're
only covering your nose and mouth
uh someone someone tweeted me about this
he said you know david maybe mike pence
is used to a type of white face mask
that does cover your entire face if you
guys know what i mean
that's a joke by the way i think as far
as i know anyway
so this is one of the dumbest
explanations and this includes the
testing thing now
mike pence says he's tested regularly
and people around him are tested
regularly
you could be incubating the disease it's
possible you could be contagious before
a test
result would come back positive we just
don't know and of course pence is flying
around
he's the last person who should be going
to a hospital without wearing a mask
if mike pence brought an asymptomatic or
pre-symptomatic early case of
coronavirus
to the mayo clinic do you realize the
amount of havoc that he could personally
wreak
it is infuriating and it is toxically
irresponsible but they don't care
now what do i think the real reason is
why mike pence didn't wear a mask
they manage by optics okay they want to
pretend
that we're on the other side of this
pandemic they want to pretend
like hey listen we're states are opening
everything's good we're about to win
if a vice president who has not been
seen wearing a mask for months during
the pandemic
all of a sudden on april 28th
for the first time wears a mask in
public the optics
are not that we've almost won now of
course we've not almost
won it would be accurate to realize that
we've not almost won
but it's management by optics and pence
doesn't want to be seen wearing a mask
what i would like to have seen is the
mayo clinic
simply deny mike pence entry now i know
it's the vice president i know he flew
there from washington dc these things
are carefully choreographed
like a dance it would have been a very
bold move for the mayo clinic to do that
but i find it more bold and certainly
more disrespectful and disgusting
for pence to go in there without a mask
you have
people who have family members at the
mayo clinic with coronavirus
family members and they're not allowed
to go visit
at all never mind with a mask because
the risk is too great
and mike pence flies in from dc and is
walking around
with no mask i hope that when this is
all over what and by that i mean
the virus and this administration and
hopefully that's sooner than later on
both counts
i hope we don't forget how incompetent
this administration is
but i also hope we don't forget how
disrespectful
and flat out terrible people this
administration
has been made up of because it is
absolutely and completely disgusting
we'll have more coverage of this on our
instagram page
at david pakman show also follow me on
instagram at david.pacman if you're
looking for a break from
bad news every day uh follow my
urban gardening experience which i am uh
reporting on consistently on my
instagram page at david.pack
we'll take a quick break and be back
right after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today rutger bregman who is a historian
and also
author of humankind a hopeful history
and the best-selling utopia for realist
you may also recognize him from such
viral moments as
that time he said the thing about taxes
at davos
and when tucker carlson flipped out on
him and tried not to air it uh
rucker great to have you on i appreciate
it thanks for having me david
so to begin with a hopeful history
humankind i'm interested in this
because particularly right now there are
many people
who who maybe don't have the most
optimistic perspective on humanity and
and on homo sapiens so
what what is your source of general
optimism
about humanity the book is really about
a sort of silent revolution that has
taken place
in science within i'd say the last 15 to
20 years
so what has happened is that scientists
from very diverse disciplines
anthropologists sociologists
psychologists you name it
have moved from maybe a little bit
cynical view of human nature to a much
more
positive hopeful view of human nature so
in the book i'm just sort of
describing this whole process and trying
to point this out because
what i discovered is that often these
scientists don't even know it from
each other right there was one
psychologist who at one point during my
research
said to me uh when i told her about you
know stuff that was happening in
biology and she said oh my god it's
happening there as well
so i just wanted to to to let people
know that this has been going on
and it may be a source for hope as well
how do you make the case
that human beings are sort of
fundamentally good
to the extent that that's a kind of
definable actionable term
well i wouldn't say that people are
fundamentally good right we're
we're clearly not angels yes what i
would say is that what you assume in
other people is often what you get out
of them
right so if you assume that most people
are selfish
and you'll start designing your
institutions around that idea you know
your schools
your marketplaces uh everything you do
in your society then that's what you get
out of people right so what you assume
is what you get i think this is actually
the defining idea of what we call
neoliberalism right
uh which is basically people are selfish
and deal with it and design everything
around it
um i think it has sort of produced the
kind of people that the theory
presupposed and i think we can turn it
around
um and in the book i try to give a lot
of examples of for example
schools or or even
organizations or even prisons that
work with this sort of different kind of
view of human nature
and then get some pretty interesting
results as well well that's what's so
interesting about it which is as you
point out
if if you take an economic perspective
if you believe people are fundamentally
greedy
you then design an economic system
around that and it has major
implications that are difficult to undo
even if people aren't fundamentally
greedy yeah if you look at
evolutionary psychology if you look at
sociol et cetera
every one of the systems we've designed
is based around
some of these core ideas so the the the
implications
are actually not just uh theoretical and
trivial
they're very real it's a quite
revolutionary idea so it must
at first it may sound like oh this guy
has written some nice happy clappy book
about how human beings are friendly
no actually the implications are really
revolutionary because
you know if we cannot trust each other
then we need them
right to keep us in check then we need
the ceos
and the managers and the bankers and the
monarchs and the generals and you name
it then we need those in power then we
need hierarchy
if actually most people are pretty
decent
and can be trusted then we can move to a
radically different society
you know that is much more egalitarian
where people have the freedom to make
their own choices
suddenly all kinds of things become
possible that initially
were not possible at all at what sort of
level of focus do you think is the right
one
to make these observations about
humanity and i'll give you an example of
what i mean
you could take for example the kitty
genovese
story of 1964 and the bystander
effect and use that to extrapolate about
human nature
or you could say hey you know what over
time
war has become less and less common
you're right these are very different
levels of focus which may get you to
different conclusions about human nature
where do you think we should start
evaluating what human nature is
well i think you need to look at all
these things um in the book i start with
a very old theory within western culture
which is the idea of
veneer theory right and the idea goes
like this
supposedly civilization is only a thin
veneer
and as soon as something happens say a
war or a natural disaster or
you ship wreck on an island then
supposedly people reveal their true
selves
and you know they show that they're
really animals and they're selfish
if you look for example the news
coverage of natural disasters it's
pretty much always like this it's always
veneer theory you know the news is full
of stories about looting and
violence and plunder you know kind of
all kinds of horrible stories
but actually what sociologists have
known basically since the 1960s is that
what you get every single time after a
natural disaster
is an explosion of cooperation people
are really working together a great
example is uh
what happened after katrina in the u.s
uh rebecca solnit has written a
fantastic book about this
a paradise built in hell but there are
many other examples
around the globe so it's really the
opposite of veneer theory
but still this theory is so deeply
entrenched
in our culture you know the idea that
deep down we're all selfish it goes back
all the way to the ancient greeks
you find it with the christian church
fathers you know the idea that we're all
born as sinners
even the enlightenment philosophers uh
david yum
adam smith i think you could argue that
the u.s
itself was sort of founded on the idea
that people are selfish if you read some
of the texts of the founding fathers
john adams for example he wrote an essay
that said all men would be tyrants if
they could
or james madison who said you know
ambition must be made to counteract
ambition you know
let's let's be real let's assume that
most people are selfish
so often when people say oh you got to
be a realist they say well don't be too
idealistic right otherwise you're naive
and so i think that the larger pro
project here is sort of to try and
redefine what it means to be a realist
is that actually the realistic
scientific position these days
is to sort of conclude that actually
human beings have evolved to cooperate
and um there's actually this process
in our evolutionary history that
biologists call survival of the
friendliest
which is very much the opposite of what
i had always
thought what role in this analysis does
the idea of a sort of
multi-layer evolutionary selection have
to play the idea
that an individual being greedy
within a group that cooperates may
may be a more relevant way to look than
simply
humans are individually greedy or not
greedy
well there are certainly different
theories right now within biology right
whether you should
look at evolution on the individual
level or
on the group level and there's a lot of
scientific debate going on there and to
be honest i don't really have
a big position here i think sort of the
more
important takeaway of you know
developments within biology of the past
couple of
years say 15 to 20 years is that
actually
uh biologists have discovered this
process of what they call survival of
the friendliest
right so for thousands of years it was
actually the friendliest among us
who had the most kids you know imagine
donald trump in
it's an impossibility you know he
wouldn't have survived for long people
wouldn't have liked him
wouldn't want to cooperate with him and
would have expelled him from the group
and probably would have died alone
right or if he was really nasty would
have been executed by the group
so um we know this from you know studies
from nomadic hunter-gatherer tribes
around the globe that being friendly
being humble was really
a prerequisite if you wanted to survive
now it's only recently
in this era that we call sort of the
civilized era
that everything has changed and nowadays
you know
there seems to be this process that we
call survival to shameless right where
so often
if you are shameless that can actually
be an advantage
which is i think highly unnatural for us
as a species because
you know one of the most fascinating
things that i discovered during my
research is that
human beings are actually the only
species in the animal kingdom
that blush you know which is a
fascinating fact that we blush
and uh for thousands of years it was an
evolutionary advantage for us because it
helped us to cooperate
and i think we need to go back to that
vision of human nature
so i want to ask about what your vision
of human nature would imply
maybe the economic system should be but
before we get to that
the veneer theory is it too early to see
if or how that applies to the world
reaction to coronavirus or or do you
have some sense of if and how that
applies
to to how we're we're currently seeing
the world react to that pandemic
[Music]
well obviously at first there were some
stories or quite a lot of stories in the
press about people hoarding toilet paper
and you know by even fighting over
toilet paper and again it was very
tempting to conclude that oh here we
have a crisis people are selfish once
again
i think by now we can zoom out and and
say that actually the vast majority of
most people has actually
been pro-social in nature most people
are actually helping each other
there's quite some evidence accumulating
now from different countries is that
you know it mostly brings out the
positive the the good
in in people you know there's so many
initiatives from the bottom up
you know groups on whatsapp and on
facebook and neighbors helping each
other etc etc
and this is all not very surprising to
sociologists because as i said you know
they've known for a very long time that
most people put together during a time
of crisis
it's not it's not what the hollywood
movies have taught you
you know it's not like panic and
everyone going nuts and crazy blah blah
it's very much the opposite
you know one of the most striking
eyewitness accounts that i discovered
during my research was
for example how some people behaved
during 9 11 you know when they were
going down the stairs of the twin tower
twin towers as they were burning and
people were literally saying no you go
first no you go first no yeah this is
crazy but it actually happened so you
talked about how
seeing human nature as fundamentally
greedy
implies or maybe justifies the
neoliberal
economic framework which is very
interesting if someone were
to accept your fundamental view of human
nature
what is the economic system that would
logically follow from that
well you could do a lot of things
actually i started writing this book
because i have first written a book
about
the idea of giving everyone a guaranteed
basic income
right so this was utopia for realist and
the book was full of studies and
examples and experiments that showed
that this could actually work
people in general have sort of two
objections against the idea and they say
well it doesn't work because
you know people are lazy and they'll
stop working or they'll say
you can't do it because people will
waste the money you know they'll just
spend it on drugs or alcor
these are like the two most common
objections and so i
sort of tried to collect all this
evidence and say you know it actually
does work
we have tried it and the the science
says it works
so i went on a bookstore in a couple of
countries and again and again
and again i found myself discussing
human nature with people
because so so often people would say
yeah okay maybe this works on a local
level
maybe this works in this particular
experiment here or there in canada or in
the us in the 70s
but that was a very different place
highly exceptional
in the end you just got to look at human
nature and be realistic
so i started to understand that for so
many of the exciting ideas
that i cared about and not only basic
income but also for example different
ways to do democracy you know
participatory democracy
they all presupposed a different view a
more hopeful view of human nature
and then i realized that actually i
didn't have that view myself
you know i had studied history i had
you know studied so many of these sort
of cynical experiments from the 60s
the stanford prison experiment or the
milgram experiment that many people will
know with the shock machine
so i started basically on a journey with
basically to see if i
if i could actually realistically adopt
a more helpful view of human nature and
that resulted in this book
and is there a specific i mean from the
point of view of the
the vast majority of so-called western
democracies
are is there low-hanging fruit or
so-called
specific policies that would be the ones
that most obviously
could be changed for the betterment of
society on the basis of your newfound
optimism oh um
well maybe it's interesting to zoom in
on prisons uh which is one of the most
radical applications of of this
theory of human nature if you go to
norway you'll find prisons that are
really really weird and strange
where they really treat inmates as if
they're actually people so
there are prisons like bostoy or helden
very close to oslo
where you'll find you know people have
been convicted of murders or rapes or
pretty horrible things but still get the
freedom
um you know to read books there's a
cinema
there's even a music studio they have
their own music label that is called
criminal records
um and and you would ev you know some
people would say well this
is like some kind of holiday resort uh
but then you
look at the science behind it right you
look at the statistics and
in particular you look at the recidivism
rate and you realize that actually
norway has the lowest recidivism rate in
the world so the chance that someone
will commit another crime
you know after he or she gets out of
prison that's the recidivism rate
is nowhere as low as in norway so these
prisons work even though they don't
really look like prisons
they're highly highly effective then you
look at
prisons in the u.s and you realize that
actually these prisons have have the
highest
recidivism rate in the world right if
you treat people like crap there will be
crap
i mean i can't make it easier than that
if you treat people like people they
will behave like people
um this in the case of prisons it really
goes against your intuition
right you really sort of uh the
intuition says
vengeance you know people who've done
these horrible things you want vengeance
you want to lock them up you want them
to suffer
um but if you um realistically look at
what works
then i think norway really leads the way
here
yeah it's also counterintuitive one one
might imagine you want
prison to be really bad so people are
more incentivized to avoid going back
and it just does not seem to actually
function function in that way
obviously and the other problem is that
prisons can become sort of universities
for crime
so this is really the case in the u.s
people people come in maybe for
small minor offenses drug offenses or
something like that and then they become
hardened criminals
in the prison system right i for the
book i looked at the history of the
of of the system in the us and it's it's
really astonishing
to find out that actually in the early
70s
you know the us experimented with
norway-style
prisons you know and it worked really
well
it's just that after that history took a
different direction same is true for
basic income by the way
the us almost implemented a guaranteed
basic income under
nixon you know there's no country that
came as close to implementing a basic
income as the u.s
uh but that didn't happen in the end no
because of a lot of bizarre coincidences
yeah even i mean between world war one
and two
there was a moment where the direction
for health care in the united states was
going towards universal health care but
it was deemed to be too much like what
was happening in germany at the time and
for
political reasons it was not pursued as
we of course uh of course now know
we've been speaking with rutger bregman
historian
author of humankind a hopeful history
and of course author of the best-selling
utopia for realists
i so appreciate your time today thank
you thank you
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so let's talk about voting by mail very
important issue in general very
important issue
acutely so right now because of the
coronavirus pandemic
i have for you today exhibit a
about why donald trump is scared to
death
and completely opposed to the november
presidential election being done as a
vote
by mail election and the reason is very
simple vote by mail means more people
vote
more people voting is not good for
donald trump and it is generally not
good for the republican party the
example comes from kansas
kansas democrats decided to do this
year's
primary or caucus as vote by mail this
is the democratic
selection in 2016 kansas voted
in person and about 39 000
people voted 39 000 in 2020
because of the pandemic it's vote by
mail and they have
already had 138
000 people vote and this is considering
that the outcome is a foregone
conclusion joe biden
uh is the only candidate left everybody
else has dropped out bernie's gone
and still with vote by mail this year
we have a turnout in kansas that is
three and a half
times that of 2016. there's almost
nothing to vote for
in a sense and turnout is orders of
magnitude greater than what it was in
2016.
so we know that vote by mail in november
of 2020 would be a turnout boosting
mechanism
we know that even pandemic aside i mean
just in a normal election
letting everybody vote by mail would
likely increase
turnout and that's not good for
republicans and that's not good for
trump
why do you think they've spent 20 years
trying to reduce the number of people
that are voting
now there are some other factors here
which could account for this
huge rise in the number of people voting
in the democratic
caucus in kansas one is you know maybe
there's a motivation
to vote against donald trump in november
uh for democrats
and it's motivating some of them early
particularly because of the incompetent
response to coronavirus so you've got a
lot of fired up kansas
democrats who whose enthusiasm for
voting in november
is being reflected in that they are also
participating in the democratic primary
that's possible that's possible but
these are
massive numbers again three and a half
times already the total turnout from
2016
and trump recently saying on multiple
occasions he doesn't want
vote by mail remember this yeah i wanted
to get back to
something you were saying yesterday
about people going to wisconsin
and voting yeah uh in the middle of this
pandemic
really putting their lives on the line
and you said well if they do that
vote by mail perhaps we'll have voter
fraud in this country i just wanted to
ask you
voters in five states utah colorado
hawaii
washington and oregon all vote by mail
can you or the white house staff or your
campaign provide any evidence to back up
your claim
the mail-in voting is right with fraud
like the example you gave of people
working in rooms filling out false
balance you've been talking about what
is
the beginning of this administration
very fair and where is the evidence
the uh i think there's a lot of evidence
but we'll provide you with some
okay and there's evidence that's being
compiled just like it's being compiled
in the state of california where they
settled with judicial watch saying that
a million people
should not have been voting and you saw
that did you wait excuse me well i'm
just telling you i'm telling you
in california in the great state of
california they settled and we could
have gone a lot further
so trump with no real answers there
because the reality is vote by mail
is not going to dramatically increase
fraud and then previously here's donald
trump admitting that
some of these ideas that democrats have
like vote by mail
these would mean republicans don't win
which may be true
in the sense that the more of the will
of the people that's represented at the
ballot box
the less likely maybe it is that a con
man like donald trump would be able to
get into the oval office take a look
here's trump admitting it
just the common facts i mean they have a
majority in the house and therefore you
need their vote and they want to get
certain things
i will tell you this if you look at
before and after the things they had in
there were
crazy they had things levels of voting
that if you ever agreed to it you'd
never have a republican elected in this
country again
levels of voting which if you had
would mean a republican never gets
elected again
this is what is being talked about and
we are seeing it
in kansas and republicans know i mean
listen
to their credit republicans aren't wrong
they know that if it's easier to vote
it's not good for them
they know that if there is less friction
if there are fewer obstacles if the
barriers to entry to voting are lower
it's not good for them because the will
of the people will be more accurately
represented by a larger share of the
population of the united states
we are seeing an example of it here all
the policy that republicans are pushing
when it comes to how elections are done
is about suppressing the vote imagine
the damage that vote by mail
would do to republican efforts to
suppress voting not because of fraud
not because of dead people voting not
because of any of that stuff
simply because a larger share of the
population
is casting a ballot so when you look
back at the last
15 years 20 years i mean you know
redistricting gerrymandering
has been going on for a while but when
you look at voter id
efforts to reduce early voting efforts
to reduce the number of polling places
efforts to purge voter rolls voter
intimidation at polling places
constantly fear-mongering about almost
mathematically non-existent
double voting voter for in-person voter
fraud
all of that stuff plus the
gerrymandering we now understand why and
it's very very clear
all of a sudden vote by mail would be
devastating
to republicans and potentially to donald
trump and so that's why they're going to
do everything they can to stop it
now let's talk about strategy a little
bit this matters more in swing states
and what i mean by that is
whatever happens between now and
november california is not going to vote
for donald trump they're going to vote
for joe biden whether it's vote by mail
whether it's voting in person turnout
may be depressed if it's voting in
person and the virus is raging
okay california is not going to be a
difference maker we have an electoral
college system
if massachusetts votes by mail or not
trump's not going to win here in
massachusetts
the important states are the ones that
are always important in the system that
we have we're talking about
michigan wisconsin pennsylvania north
carolina florida
the places that could turn the election
from trump to biden or vice versa
that's where we need to be working extra
hard to get vote by mail
who is it going to be up to well it's
ultimately going to be up to
each individual state it's going to be
up to the governor it's going to be up
to the
state legislatures in those states this
is why once again local elections matter
when you look at many of the progressive
successes of the 20th century
what made sure that those reforms
stuck was having a supreme court that
would uphold
them that's called doing the groundwork
and much the same way
what could be the factor i mean i don't
believe it's hyperbolic to say
that the november of 2020 election could
hinge on
is there a republican or democratic
governor is there a republican or
democratic state legislature if it
ultimately hinges on do they get to vote
by mail
or not those are decisions that we can
go back to when the state legislatures
were elected
to when the gubernatorial elections
happened this is why every election
matters
and has to be taken seriously
republicans are scared
the numbers in kansas tell us exactly
why they should be scared
donald trump's former white house
communications director anthony
scaramucci
has again admitted something which i've
been covering for years at this point
which is
that donald trump has difficulty reading
he really doesn't read and he
struggles to read anthony scaramucci has
been doing interviews recently
he's been more honest than maybe we are
used to hearing from people who worked
for trump or who work for trump
and he's admitted to a number of things
including that donald trump can't read
very well check out this clip from an
interview with
anand giridara das who's been a
previous guest on the david pakman show
as well i'm not i'm not
i'm not a diagnostician but my guess is
that he probably had
an undiagnosed learning disability as a
kid
maybe it's a form of dyslexia or
something like that
and so his reading comprehension levels
are not
where his iq possibly is okay now he's
in decline right now
but you'd have to stipulate that he's a
reasonably smart guy i mean he built
a business he built a uh
you know television show he had made a
name for himself and in 17 short months
he went from being a reality television
star
to the presidency of the united states
so we have to stipulate
that there's intelligence in there but
it's what kind of intelligence
so scaramucci is obviously not saying it
in as definitive or aggressive terms as
we have suggested before but scaramucci
also knows
that trump struggles to read and he
makes it clear there this is not making
fun of people
this is not making fun of learning
disabilities this is simply pointing out
don't we need a president who can read
well and regularly reads
we suspect trump hasn't read a book in
his adult life
there's no evidence that trump has read
a book in his adult life he's never
mentioned reading anything other than
his own book art of the deal which he
didn't write
tony schwartz wrote it and the bible
which you know if you believe trump
reads the bible okay i may have a bridge
to sell you
but remember that i've been covering
this for years and there's interest in
it and a lot of agreement back in
february of 2017 we did a story called
trump fails basic literacy test it got
nearly
3.4 million views on youtube another 7
million on facebook
this was subsequently picked up around
the world including
in france in other countries and it
explains a lot now
not being able to read well doesn't mean
trump's a bad person
not being able to read well doesn't mean
trump is wrong on policy
he is usually wrong on policy but for
other reasons
but it explains a lot to quote donald
trump
including things like this from earlier
this week dickinson
holagic and cephei
sefer hyde this reading deficit
has been widely corroborated saturday
night live's pete davidson
said when trump was hosting snl trump
couldn't
seem to read the scripts i've played
this clip for you before
what happened with the trump story okay
so he's like
he doesn't really know how to read for
real yeah and he loves to
improv yes so during like the table read
he like before like we were gonna
read each before he had to read each
line and he's the host so he's at
everything yeah
he would go uh i'm not going to say this
i think i'm going to say it the way i
want to say is that okay
is it okay lauren is it everything
literally and everybody's like what
and then this is my favorite part is
there was a sketch that we wrote
where he's at disneyland with his
daughter
and the line is uh all right let's get
out of here
turkey legs like let's let's go get
turkey legs
and he doesn't know how to read so he
went all right let's get out of here
turkey legs
he called his daughter turkey legs
maybe that was his improv oh no it
wasn't and then he looked
like he doesn't get it like he thinks if
everybody's laughing with him
but we're all laughing at him so that's
not new we've covered that previously
noel kasler worked with trump on the
apprentice
and says trump couldn't read although
with noel casler it seemed maybe
it was more about trump's inability to
sit still
rather than simply not being able to
read no casler
you know we've heard about the the
possible uppers stuff with the
apprentice
so the point is we know from sources
inside the white house
trump's presidential daily briefings
have been reduced from what's normally
many pages of text to just a couple of
pages
to just one page to just one page that
is half
charts and graphs and even that trump is
accepting with low frequency so
this is not good and the reason it's not
good is because it's tough to be
informed if you're not reading
a lot as president that's how barack
obama
was informed that's how george george w
bush read a lot he read
a you know political material he also
just read books we know that doesn't
mean bush is a great guy doesn't mean he
was a great president but
he was reading at least he came to many
wrong decisions but he was reading
bill clinton spent a ton of time reading
intelligence reporting books etc
trump simply doesn't do it and all
politics aside
that's a fundamental liability when
you're president of the united states
it's sad more than anything
but it has a real effect on trump's
ability to be a leader
and it's not a good effect i'll tell you
that right now we have a voicemail
number that number is 2192 david p
yesterday we talked about when it comes
to people who hear trump talk about
injecting bleach and they go and they
ingest
bleach uh should we care about that is
it a darwinian thinning of the herd
should we
uh not care about the plight of the cond
here's a voicemail about exactly that
issue
hey david jeff in oregon hey i heard you
say
suggesting that we should absolve
trump's followers
but my take is is there is no con man
without
suckers there is no cult leader
without cult followers certainly
republican politicians who know better
should be held criminally culpable but
his followers need to be deprogrammed
and must look in the mirror and
and think of what they've caused
listen i i am not trying to absolve
people who go and inject bleach of any
responsibility but
the caller says they need to be
deprogrammed well
that means that they've been programmed
to begin with
and they didn't program themselves so i
think that there's plenty of blame to go
around
we have an education system that is
failing people we have a political
system that is failing people we have an
economic
system that is failing people i'm not
looking to absolve anybody of the
actions that they choose
uh to take and of personal
responsibility but i do
stop short of saying hey let's absolve
the con men
of any responsibility and simply
criticize those who have been caught
that doesn't seem right to me either
we've got a terrific bonus show for you
today don't miss it become a member or
patron
today to get instant access i'll talk to
you then
or otherwise tomorrow
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
you